[Music]
I'm Dale Talde chef partner and
addictions restaurant group and we are
at my restaurant in Kona see my point of
reference are splitting who is always
with this version of adobo that my mom
makes
that's with baby squid the squid ink
tastes like like the animal or the squid
version of what capers are as this brine
enos this like really intense like
oceanic flavor but it's and it's
slightly fishy but in almost in a fresh
way
[Music]
so our squid ink pappardelle with blue
crab it starts with the pops itself like
in any traditional Italian dish pasta is
the main event right so we use semolina
durum flour we take squid ink mix it
with the egg yolks in a little bit of
water and do salt how do we mix it
together and then we roll it out cut fat
ribbons out of it cook the pasta for a
minute and a half 10 seconds either way
that pasta your fall right so
undercooked overcooked you're [ __ ]
we've warmed up the sauce with a warm
crab meat and it's just tossing it
together a little bit of pasta water and
then it's done and the sauce is a class
of five cut-offs right so you know it's
basic tomato onion we wanted to put a
little old band to kind of give it some
light and personality that wasn't just a
typical vodka sauce then we added some
like toasted bread crumbs and some
scallion it's kind of how that just came
together
would a typical Sicilian grandmother
push you know old day in Subaru socks
probably not but for us it just made
sense for also like let's put the best
of our efforts for a secret pasta into
this dish so for me it's really a labor
of love we worked a lot on that dish
like probably more than anything that's
why I passion models you really
important on the [ __ ] thing forever
you know I am always I'm always kind of
mesmerized by that color it's beautiful
the red and the flecks of white with
over the black pasta to me it's a
beautiful play about them